[Musique]
c'est un festival qui est plutôt axé
chanson francophone et qui existe depuis
35 ans dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
en fait il y a plusieurs scènes dans les
Yvelines là vous êtes au théâtre de
Poissy donc je vais vous parler plus
spécialement de ce qui va se passer à
Poissy dans le cadre de l'Estival donc
on va ouvrir le 17 septembre avec
Véronique Sanson un concert dans le parc
Maisonnier et puis ensuite toute une
série de d'artistes il y aura aussi bien
aussi Yannick Noah Zaz Juliette Armanet
et puis on terminera avec Émile et
images Gold et images
je pense que ce sont différents lieux
qui ont tous leur particularité c'est de
la chanson francophone mais dans tous
les sens du terme c'est à dire ça va
bien bien sûr de la chanson au jazz au
rap enfin bref il y a différentes choses
au rock bien évidemment puisque on
recevra de nombreux artistes sur les
salles extérieures aussi qui sont des
salles gratuites pour le public
c'est un festival qui a toujours mis en
valeur les jeunes artistes donc des
premières parties des podiums le
week-end pro comme je vous le disais où
il y a ce qu'on appelle les vitrines
découvertes et on reçoit 6 artistes qui
vont venir se présenter devant un public
et en plus de ça c'est gratuit les
vitrines découvertes de l'estive
[Musique]